when you rub like this it stretches your
skin and the product is not going to
absorb as well this is actually an
illusion this is your skin your blood is
down here Your Skin Barrier is up here
and that's what's mostly preventing
absorption increasing circulation down
here doesn't really help up here maybe
it's getting a little bit warmer and
heat does help things absorb but it's
not helping that much what is really
happening is that when you're rubbing
you're putting the product on your face
as well as maybe two finger pads when
you're slapping you're putting the
product on your whole face plus both of
your hands that is the same amount of
product over a much bigger surface area
so it's drying out a lot faster you're
applying a thinner layer so it feels
like it's absorbing better the other
thing that's happening is you are
Fanning your face and so that product is
drying out faster and a big part of what
feels like absorption is actually water
from the product evaporating into the
air so you can still slap your skincare
on that is fine but don't do it because
you think it's absorbing better